build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people
this is bdp building in the Arizona
desert Ernie Adams is building miniature
versions of classic cars by hand from
scratch including a 1939 Chevy sedan a
1929 Ford hillbilly and a 1949 mercury
atoms even builds the tools that are
necessary for the creations and it takes
him between one and five years to
construct each one he calls them dwarf
cars and some are even street-legal and
they're on display at the dwarf car
Museum in Arizona Domenico Corolla makes
celebrity inspired pizza art including
Gordon Ramsay Rihanna Donald Trump
MORTAL KOMBAT and Tom Ford but he says
although he doesn't want to be typecast
as a pizza chef he happens to be very
good at making pizza and it's his
favorite food reconnected is an art
installation by Philip Hanford in pendel
England at the location where an
infamous hanging took place over 400
years ago bridging the past and present
day cruelty Hanford decided to connect
the stumps of fallen trees cut down
illegally by using metal frames that
look like spines so the trees appear
frozen in time where they fell rated
Michael off ski made this mig-23 fighter
jet arcade cabinet that was inspired by
living near the gait of a fighter air
regiment in Poland it's numbered 846 in
tribute to a plane that his friend's
father flew and it's for sale at Etsy
for 3,350 $8.75 draw artist Natalie Eve
Guerra created this series of fairytale
art made out of yogurt including
characters like Goldilocks Rapunzel
Little Red Riding Hood and
mermaid Adrienne Notre Dame Simpson eyes
the Game of Thrones characters by
illustrating each character as they
would be seen on The Simpsons some of
the characters include Joffrey Daenerys
Targaryen Khal Drogo and Tyrion
Lannister check out a site for more
Simpson eyes characters and now for the
surrealistic art of Moscow based artist
Dimitri maximov
uncured is a photo series by Ben de Haan
of melting portraits he used a type of
printer where the ink dries using UV
light but disabled that function so the
photos slowly drip and then he
photographed the dripping to create this
effect fly it here's a really cool base
cover of Daft Punk's get lucky by Jim
Bennett youtuber Chad now created this
one-minute mashup of 20 famous
commercial jingles give me a break break
me off these that just grew it's gonna
move yeah I'm a big kid now but the very
best part of all is there's a counter on
this ball artist Mauro fortissimo is
installing pianos along the coastline of
Northern California for his project
sunset piano opus 2 for 12 pianos where
12 pianos have been made available to
the public so anyone can play them at
any time
it's needed to pay for the crew with the
rental and the documentary film has
already began production we acquire the
pianos but there is still so much to be
done help us bring some piano opus 2 for
12v a nose to life finally direct from
sweet and here's the metal version of
Knox or umpqua done by vsauce fans means
and composed by Eric Whitacre and this
guy's voice is seriously awesome
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo wo
click here listen to a brand new
installment of bidipi radio music
created and submitted by you guys also
check out your bidipi
an entire video dedicated to your
creations
this is the 200th vsauce2 video which
seems incredible and I just wanted to
thank all of you that have been with the
channel since day one and those of you
who just recently subscribed and found
these videos you know someone on Twitter
recently sent me a message saying I love
your videos please keep making them and
I immediately thought well yeah why
would I stop you guys are literally the
coolest audience and with so many
amazing things happening all around the
world to talk about
will there be 200 more videos I don't
know you're just gonna have to stick
around and find out and as always thanks
for watching